face au ralentissement de la campagne
vaccinale aux états unis joe biden a
décidé de durcir le ton avec une mesure
annoncée ce jeudi celle de contraindre
les employés fédéraux du pays a présenté
une preuve de vaccination ou à défaut de
devoir réaliser un voire deux tests pcr
chaque semaine ainsi que de porter le
masque sur leur lieu de travail
quant aux militaires joe biden laisse la
possibilité au pentagone de trancher sur
la possibilité d'ajouter ou non le
vaccin contre locaux vides 19 sur la
liste des vaccins déjà obligatoire pour
les forces armées du pays
quant à une éventuelle obligation sur
l'ensemble de la population américaine
joe biden dit ne pas savoir encore si le
gouvernement fédéral en a la possibilité
joe biden qui a donc délivré un discours
relativement solonnel où il a une
nouvelle fois imploré l'ensemble des
américains à se faire vacciner lui qui
explique que les états unis font face à
une pandémie des non vaccinés ou la
quasi totalité des personnes qui
décèdent actuellement du commis 19 ne se
sont pas fait vacciner
écoutez la vérité c'est que plus la
population se fait vacciner plus nous
sommes protégés en tant que nation pour
continuer à rouvrir en toute sécurité de
manière responsable
nous ne sommes pas encore tirés
d'affaires car ce qui se passe
actuellement en amérique est une
pandémie
une pandémie parmi les personnes non
vaccinées je le répète encore une fois
c'est une pandémie parmi les personnes
non vaccinées
parallèlement à ces mesures d'
obligations qui ne disent pas leur nom
il ya aussi une forme d'incitation que
veut promouvoir le président américain
en permettant par exemple aux
entreprises de libérer leurs salariés
sur leur temps de travail sans frais
pour que ceux ci puissent aller se faire
vacciner ou encore permettre aux états
de délivrer une somme de 100 dollars
pour chaque américain qui irait se faire
vacciner à partir de maintenant joe
biden qui encourage aussi les
entreprises privées à mettre en place
les mêmes mesures que lui impose aux
employés fédéraux
quant au port du masque on sait que les
autorités sanitaires ont changé leurs
recommandations il ya quelques jours en
recommandant désormais le port du masque
dans les zones à risque pour tous pour
les personnes vaccinées comme pour les
vacciner et ces lieux c'est aussi les
écoles le port du masque à l'école fait
débat ici aux etats-unis notamment
auprès d'un certain nombre d'élus
républicains qui s'y opposent c'est le
cas par exemple du gouverneur de floride
rhône de santis qui a pris des mesures
pour empêcher toute mise en place d'une
quelconque obligation du port du masque
dans les établissements scolaires de
l'état de floride autres personnes qui
s'opposent à ce port du masque pour les
plus jeunes c'est donald trump qui a
vivement critiqué ce changement dans les
recommandations des autorités sanitaires
américaines